- [Instructor] In previous videos,
we had talked about the
1896 Supreme Court case,
Plessy versus Ferguson,
which is a good one to know in general
if you're studying United States history
and/or United States government.
But this is where we got the principle
of separate but equal
where the Supreme Court said in 1896
that it was okay to have segregation.
It was okay to separate
folks on a racial basis
as long as what they got was equal.
This was a case around whether
it was unconstitutional
for an African-American in Louisiana
to have to sit in a separate
rail car from white passengers.
Now, as you can imagine,
this idea of segregation
and separate but equal,
it was taken to justify racial segregation
in all walks of life,
including in schools.
And what you see here is a
map of the United States,
and it's colored in by the
degree of school segregation,
educational segregation,
as we enter into the 1950s.
And what you could see is
in these red states here,
which is for the most
part the Southern states,
it required the separation of races.
In the green states you see here
segregation was forbidden.
And in the yellow and blue
states it was kind of in between.
The yellow states had no legislation,
and in the blue states it was limited.
It wasn't required.
And all of this comes to a head as we get
into the 1950s in Topeka, Kansas.
You have a situation where the NAACP
in coordination with 13 parents
tried to register
African-American students
into white schools in Topeka, Kansas.
The schools tried to prevent them,
and it eventually goes to the
United States Supreme Court
in the case of Brown
versus Board of Education
of Topeka 1954.
Oliver Brown was one of those 13 parents
trying to get his daughter
into an otherwise segregated school.
And this is a seminal Supreme Court case
because here the Supreme
Court revisits segregation
and essentially overturns
Plessy versus Ferguson.
The Supreme Court, in
a unanimous decision,
ruled, We conclude that, in
the field of public education,
the doctrine of separate
but equal has no place.
Separate educational facilities
are inherently unequal.
Therefore, we hold that
the plaintiffs and others
similarly situated for whom
the actions have been brought
are, by reason of the
segregation complained of,
deprived of the equal
protection of the laws
guaranteed by the 14th Amendment.
And we cite the 14th Amendment
a lot in these Supreme Court cases.
And it never hurts to take another look
at at least an excerpt
of the 14th Amendment.
And this is a focus on the
equal protection clause.
This is part of Section
1 of the 14th Amendment.
Nor shall any State
deprive any person of life,
liberty, or property,
without due process of law.
And then this is the
equal protection clause.
Nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction
the equal protection of the laws.
And this is a big deal
because not only does it say
that hey, segregation is
fundamentally unconstitutional.
What's also interesting about this
is that this unanimous ruling
by the United States Supreme Court
then sets off a whole series of actions
by politicians from
those states that you saw
where segregation was mandatory
to try to go around the
Supreme Court's decision.
And so it's a case of how
other branches of government
might try to limit Supreme Court powers
or try to ignore, in some
cases, Supreme Court powers.
A good example of this was
Virginia Senator Harry Byrd.
In 1956, shortly after the Brown versus
Board of Education decision,
he issues the Southern Manifesto
where he gets 100 politicians in the South
to essentially sign on saying, hey,
we are going to do what
we can, legislatively,
to try to get around the Brown versus
Board of Education decision.
We are going to try to ensure
that that does not go into effect
in segregated states like Virginia.
And later that year, in 1956,
it took the form of this
massive resistance movement
where they had the Stanley Plan,
named after the Virginia governor
in which they started to pass laws
to try to make Brown
versus Board of Education
not take effect.
One of them, for example,
said that any school that
actually desegregated
would not receive state funds,
and it authorized the governor
to close those schools down.
And this massive resistance continued,
and it was challenged in the
courts all the way to 1959
where you actually have the
first integrated schools
in the state of Virginia.
Another state-level
challenge to the ruling
by the Supreme Court happened in 1957
where the governor of
Arkansas, Orval Faubus,
tried to actively prevent nine students,
nine African-American students,
from attending Little
Rock Central High School.
And so what you see in
this picture over here,
these are US Army troops
sent by President Eisenhower
to escort these nine students
into Little Rock Central High School.
These nine students are famously known
as the Little Rock Nine.
And this is actually a picture
of Governor Orval Faubus
later complaining about this intervention.
And this continues on for some time.
You fast forward to 1963.
This is Alabama Governor George Wallace
physically using himself to block
two African-American
students from registering
at the University of Alabama.
Once again, in this situation,
the president had to take action.
This time John F. Kennedy, he
federalized the National Guard
and he made them force
Governor Wallace to step aside
so that those students could register
at the University of Alabama.
So the big picture here is
that Brown versus Board of Education
is a seminal case in American history,
but it also tells us how
the legislative branch
and state government might
try to go around decisions
that they don't like.
Sometimes they might
just ignore the decision
until they're forced
to pay attention to it.
Or they might try to
legislate their way around it
and have a fight in the court system
until they're forced to
go one way or the other.